o sol bem vindos e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma mini floresta
eu fiz já estava mais ou menos um ano
atrás muitas pessoas gostaram e pediram
para fazer uma palestra e que está o
resultado disso pode haver o arco igual
e depois acrescenta este corpo aqui tem
um gatilho é bastante simples é um
sistema da banca só juntar dois
pontinhos assim no ângulo de 90 graus e
funciona muito bem teve um furo da manhã
revela todo o historial e claro vocês
fizerem isso tem que usar óculos de
proteção tem responsáveis por disparar
este fósforos equipes são usados somente
para atender as lareiras carregar que só
porque o filme bastante simples que
achar flecha
os testes vão vir isto então somente pra
contra a lei preta é isso então vamos
aos testes pois o tutorial passa boy
então vamos lá quando vocês podem parar
não sabe vários pontinhos de picolé
momento de comprar embalagens que trazem
sangue então 50 e custa à volta de um
dom de qualquer coisa no brasil custa
dois reais e mãe pelo que ouvi nos
comentários em portugal estava um herói
maio
acho que o curta e seus problemas com o
mesmo tamanho em que basicamente eu
terei a extremidade depois tenha lhe
mais dois pontinhos em que só não tem
uma das extremidades e depois um pouco
em cima do outro e fiz duas montagens
destas usar como quinto mas se vocês
quiserem podem usar super cola e fica
melhor em termos de apresentação e fica
mais resistente só começou a fazer o
tutorial de um colar todos os anos super
cola é muito grande então eu tento usar
o mínimo possível mas em que marquei
quatro e sete centímetros e depois de
popular que aquelas montagem de dois
pontinhos de um lado e do outro
você talvez não estejam a preparar mas
tal geralmente desnivelado em que é que
os poucos mercados que estão diretamente
levantados por cima mais ou menos em
2013 espera criar o canal debita o canal
da besta certo para evitar que as coisas
caiam por um lado só que depois de
decolar e que aos pouquinhos têm que
circular mais dois tudo cinza e à frente
para computar um canal para frente ainda
tem duas partes ele traz têm que ser
preenchidas só que vou fazer isso depois
usando um tênis verde e vocês vão ver
oque eu comecei a fazer a parte mais
difícil porque é isso aqui eo bpi eu
ensinar agora aquelas nível pintando à
vista
hortense 90 graus até maio no espaço e
depois em que dizia estar um pouco
usando um x-ato isso usará que os dados
parecem dos médicos e tal
vejam que eu cortei agora 2% de um com 2
cm e outro com três centímetros
e usando crise super cola vou colocá los
no ângulo de 90 graus
apesar de fazer um buraco eu vou usar
uma furadeira
mas vocês não tiverem uma furadeira é
podem fazer como faca carvão faca
enfiada vão rodando a faca no lado
depois do outro até que os orifícios
junto em ok
mas qual é mais fácil assim se você
estiver em uma broca bem pequenina e
fazer o furo ea gente fazer um furo você
tem que ver se a broca tem o tamanho do
produto químico vocês vão usar agora
nesta para usar um pouquinho de
churrasco
se vocês quiserem podem usar um
pouquinho de dentro então focus também
segue o tamanho ou exportar
desta maneira muito fácil só lhe ajudar
o time até que eu fico estado está feito
obtido a parte mais difícil jogar o
resto é bastante simples
eu vou para cortar um pedacinho com 45
centímetros em que depois passa de um
corte de 45 graus e vão precisar de dois
pontinhos iguais àquelas o foral outro
marcaram encurtar para um cidade de
marcar o maio um dos meus pilotos tinham
11 centímetros que tanto maio é a 5 e
maio
depois por lá o coxinha e marquei a
largura dela tem claro que os pedacinhos
de cada lado daquela partida marcada
para daqui dos vinhos verdes e
rebrotando sinal em termos de design e
tentar lá mas vocês podem ir aos
passageiros atrás vocês quiserem pois
vocês vêem um de o final
vocês percebem que dá para encher os
coquinhos importante é que estejam lá só
para dar aquela altura pequenina eu vou
usar um elástico porque do lado mas
quiserem podem usar 26 voz elásticos
forem freqüentes para esta partida
bastante difícil é que na edição parece
fácil o trabalho para afastar os
cultivos um do outro
agora se vocês quiserem podem usar
alguma coisa para ajudar nos a abrir
espaço e pra finalizar o ar que tem por
fio
e põe cola no fio para que eu não saio
placa e se você não precisa nem colar e
o tempo eo vai fugir e vai pra detenção
largo usar o ponto frio barbante
é bom ser agora o segredo o segredo é
usar pó de talco só o que faz do total
eu diminui a resistência ao atrito
então se vocês quiserem os pontinhos e o
portal tem que entrar mesmo lá dentro a
canon inep
sim mas entende que a mesma lhe na parte
em que a flexão e e pronto vai aumentar
assim a força do arco porque diminui o
atrito para fazer um corte aqui gastando
green e é aquela parte que vai sobrar
vai encaixar no mais dois pontinhos do
arco vejam aqui vocês quisessem podiam
parar já que é só coar o ar o corpo da
besta deixar isso mais bonito é só fazer
o que eu vou fazer agora que eu vi e
tenham cuidado para um plano de melhoria
e fuja ver não ficar em cima do retiro
até o objetivo tem que funcionar
normalmente pois convém mais um
pedacinho para fazer a crônica é isso aí
tem mais ou menos r 15 talvez assim é
hoje começaram melhor e depois preencher
que dois lados que faltavam
fica assim mais bonita ver por que não
usar o calor quando fiz a parte da
frente pois cumpre um pouco em cima do
outro
para fazer esta partida vai comer um
deles é só colocar em cima disso traçar
cortei e depois os ângulos bom conhecido
na perfeição usar bastante cola
e eu lembro se vocês quiserem usar cola
super cola é podem só existem mais
pirado isso mais devagar para não
descolar em todos
agora vou usar aqui dois pontinhos
popular modo até para equilibrar o
diguinho é um pouquinho do churrasco ok
seja quando pronto o inverno vai para
ali white foi culpa do churrasco e assim
vai ficar mais bonita e aqui é o todo
não vai sair pra fora
a equipe fez um treino com bola mas
então fui tirando e agora só falta mais
uma coisinha que faltava qualquer coisa
à minha frente então não sabe o que é
uma coisa que eu lembro uma metralhadora
que já não lembro o nome
depois colocando por cima quando vocês
colocaram a flecha
vocês conseguem ajudar o argo guarda
vista em qualquer ângulo que a faixa não
vai sair
estou aqui conversando não é só para
lembrar que estava a usar sempre usa
óculos no tutorial porque quando cordas
ou qualquer coisa os potentes ao
cancelar alguns proteção em tempo real
se inscrevam caso não seja inscrito já
uma sugestão sobre já nos comentários
tchau portas banho